All right, for the final section of our calibration course,
we are going to take a look at using the Arucos we just built
to do our LED wall alignment and Arucos implementation.
Now, if you remember,
we just went through and built
our Aruco markers in the last video section.
We also built a blueprint that allows us to turn on and
off those Aruco markers on the wall so that we
have the ability to view them in our lens file.
So let's jump over to the engine.
So if you look over in the engine here,
I can see that my Aruco markers are active.
But if I look at the LED wall right now,
you can see that those markers are not active currently.
In order to enable them and make sure that they are active,
go back into the engine and we're going to go down
into our outliner and select our NDC asset.
Then we're going to make sure that our asset is selected in
the details panel and scroll
down all the way down to the default section.
In the default section, we have a replace viewport textures.
We just go ahead and switch back to the wall,
and when I click this,
you'll see that the markers pop right back on.
So now we're pointed in the right direction
for what we're going to capture,
but we need to be able to see that by going into
the engine and making sure that
we have activated our lens file.
Now, I want to make sure that we're doing this correctly.
So let's close this and we'll go back in here,
and you can see I've got my lens file,
it's checked out, and it is ready for me to use.
Now, you can also see that right now
my alignment isn't quite lined up.
Now, to get started, I can always go all the way to one,
and you can see that that's my CG overlay,
or go back down to zero,
which is how we're going to set
our transparency to make sure that we're ready to go.
Now, I'm going to make this full screen
so you can see what we're doing.
I am going to make sure that I move
over to my nodal offset tab.
I'm going to make sure I change from
my nodal offset points method to my Arruco markers section,
and then I'm going to choose my calibrator and
choose my NDC as my calibrator.
Check on show detection,
and I'm ready to get started here.
So with my first set that's ready to go,
I'm just going to go ahead and click in the screen.
Now, I'm getting a calibration error.
So I have my calibration error that says it can't find
the appropriate Arruco dictionary for the calibrator.
I'm going to click okay here,
and I'm going to go back up to my calibrator point,
and I'm going to take a look at what we've got in here.
Now, I have all of my meshes that are active,
but I don't see my calibration points.
That's what's causing this issue,
and there is a fix for this,
because this is a known bug right now
that we are trying to fix.
I don't want to make sure that you're aware of this.
You don't pull your hair out and end up like me.
So in order to fix this,
you just go back up to your NDC editor,
and you want to make sure that your points exist
in your Arruco.
So we'll just select one of our sidewall points.
We take a look at the Arrucos that are in here,
and if we scroll down,
you can see that in my sub points under calibration,
I have my dictionary in here.
So my sub points exist,
but if I move back over to my NDC asset,
and I move down here into the assets details panel,
and I select that same Arruco section,
you're going to find that in my calibration,
under my details,
I moved down here and you can see under the LED walls,
my sub points don't exist.
Now, in order to reconnect those,
I don't need to create new Arrucos.
All I got to do is hit this reset property
to its default value.
And by doing that,
this should populate all of my map elements.
So when I open this up,
I can see that my dictionary is there.
Now, I need to make sure that I do this
for all three of my Arrucos.
Let's go ahead and select this again,
hit my reset,
and you can see that my map elements fill in.
And now let's go back to our top one,
which is my main wall,
and do this one more time.
Now all my elements are active,
so let's go back to my lens file.
Now I'm back to my full screen,
and if I look at my Arrucos calibration point,
I should see these populate.
Now, if I don't see these populate,
I can go ahead and close this window
and just relaunch my lens file.
Now with my lens file active,
again, go to my normal offset,
choose my Arrucos markers,
go ahead and choose my NDC asset,
and now I should see all of my library parts.
Now, the thing about the library parts
is that while these fill in,
it is a little bit hard to find what we're looking for.
So as I'm looking for it,
I am going to scroll down,
and what I'm actually looking for is the sidewall.
You can see there's a slight break here.
This is my sidewall.
So I'm gonna make sure that this is set
for my calibrator point.
I'm gonna go ahead and hit show detection,
and I'm gonna set my transparency down to zero
so that I'm looking at the wall.
Now, as I get ready to create my calibration,
the first thing I need to do
is just click right here in the screen.
Now, you can see that I've got my calibration point
and I've got my ID showing up as well.
Now, all I need to do is move my camera around
in order to capture some images at different levels
so that I get down my sidewall
and get all of my Arrucos in the image.
So you can see Sean's moving this down.
He wants to move down just a little bit more
so we can get the three sets of markers in the middle.
This should be enough.
So right here, I'm ready to go ahead
and capture my next image.
I'm gonna click on this,
and you can see I'm getting most of my markers.
And while it failed to identify one of them, that's okay,
because hopefully it'll pick it up in the next set.
So let's move on down the wall again,
and as we move down the wall,
we might want to angle
and make sure that we get all of the bottom.
Now, let's go ahead and click on this
and see if we get all of our Arrucos.
Now, we don't.
We're missing our top row,
so I'm gonna have to have Sean go ahead
and aim that up just a little bit.
All right, now I can get my entire row of Arruco markers.
Now, if he just points that down,
I can finish getting the entire bottom row.
Now, I've got my entire bottom row set,
and my ID is ready to go.
Now, I'm gonna go ahead
and switch my Arruco's calibration to my main wall,
and then from here, while Sean has that active,
I want a little bit of my side wall to still show up,
and I want that so that I can make sure
that I can see the continuous line between these two.
So I'm gonna go ahead and click,
and I got three of the markers on that side,
and I got a couple on the other side as well.
Now, that wasn't great
because one of these is a little wobbly,
so it's really important that we lock these down
before we take our images.
So I'm gonna take this image one more time,
and now we've got a better calibration on those markers
that didn't get clicked.
Now, we just roll down a little bit,
and then we can click,
and we didn't get one of these markers,
but that should be fine because we have four in that row,
and we should be able to get more towards the middle.
So let's go ahead and move down to point at the bottom,
and now we're gonna click,
and we're gonna have to do this just one more time,
so I'm just gonna hide this and click once more
and get a better set
so that you can see that the outline is correct
and it's identifying all of them correctly.
Now, let's go ahead and move that over towards the middle
so we get some overlap in our markers.
That should be good right there.
Let's lock that down, and now I'm going to click,
and I'm gonna have to do this one more time
because it looks like we got a little bit of drift,
and now I'm gonna click,
and that's a little better on the alignment.
So now let's move that up and stop,
and from here, we can go ahead and click again.
That's a good calibration image.
Let's scroll up to the top.
We should be able to get the rest of these.
Lock that down,
and it's really important that you lock them down
so that everything that we get captured is in frame.
Now, one of the things that we did lose here
is we lost two of the markers in the bottom section,
so we wanna drop down just a little bit
because if you look over into the screen,
you'll see that there's some of the top here.
We have some extra space at the top.
We just wanna make sure that we are seeing everything,
but we're not cutting off
any of the areas in the top and bottom.
So let's actually move that over
just a little bit to the right,
and then we'll take this image again.
Much better.
Now we can move over to the corner side.
I wanna make sure that as we get over here,
we grab some of the wild wall as well, and I'll click.
Okay, so I'm getting all the markers,
and I'm getting some of my wild wall in here,
and that's a good calibration image.
So let's go ahead and scroll that down,
and once that's locked down, and I can click.
That's a good calibration.
Now we can grab the bottom,
and once he locks that down, I'm gonna click,
and I'm probably gonna have to grab this one once more.
So I'm gonna have Sean turn it
just lightly towards the right.
Much better.
All right, now we just point right at the wild wall,
and with our wild wall active and ready to go,
we can go ahead and click.
That's gonna give us a lot of markers here,
and that's good, and we can still see some on the side
so we can see that our alignment is there.
Now I'm gonna have Sean move up just a little bit
so we get the rest of the wild wall at the top,
and this'll be our last image.
Once that's locked down, I can click.
All right, so that's a good set,
and that gives us our Arruco markers.
Now, once that's done,
we just need to apply this to our marker set.
Now, the reason we hit this apply to camera parent
is because what we're actually applying to
is our track offset actor.
So this is where the camera is parented in.
This is why we built the offset actor to begin with
so that it didn't throw anything around.
And once that's done,
it's gonna add that offset to our tracking origin.
So now we're gonna point right at the center of the wall.
This way, we can see as many markers as we can,
top to bottom, and once we lock that down,
we'll be good to go.
Now, if I take a look here through my transparency,
you can see I'm still not aligned,
and when I'm ready to apply that to my camera parent,
which is this button right here,
it'll give me the option of being able
to verify my calibration points.
Now, again, I wanna verify
that I'm using my Arruco's markers
and that my calibrator is my end display asset.
I have multiple values, I'm showing detection,
and my calibrator points here
are listing all of my detection points.
Now, before I do that, I do wanna point one thing out.
If you're going through
and you have your Arruco markers available here,
there is an option to allow you to see and view
some visualization points in the editor.
So what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna enable the visualization points in editor,
and you can see that the calibration points
for my Arruco's are gonna show up here.
And just go back to your NVC here,
and let's go down to our Arruco's
and make sure that our map points are showing up.
So since those are showing up,
we should still see our calibration points
when they are there.
Now, to make sure the visualization points in editor
is active, we just go ahead
and make sure that that is there.
And if I jump back into my NVC asset,
you should still see that.
Just toggle these on and off, and we should be good to go.
Now, I lost my session here to the wall,
so I'm just gonna reconnect that really quickly
since my control node is still active.
So let's go ahead and reconnect my display devices.
Now, as I reconnect my display devices,
we should be able to see what's actually happening
because we do need to have the visualization
of the wall active in here.
And if I look right now,
you can see that we have no wall right there.
All right, so we're back.
Go ahead and choose my NDC asset again,
and we can see that my Arruco's have shown back up.
So I was able to recover this, no problem.
Let's view it.
You can see that my points are visible in editor.
You can see my little points showing up.
And you can see that I've got my calibration points
that are already collected,
so my images should still be aligned.
And now I'm ready to apply these points
into my calibrator.
So I'm gonna go ahead and apply my points
to camera parent, just like that.
And that should create my alignment.
Now, if this worked out the way it's supposed to,
I will be able to visually see
that my alignment is in here.
And if I adjust my transparency,
you can see that my points are aligned.
So my alignment actually worked here.
Now, as I scroll back through these,
you can kind of see that my alignment is there.
This is a pretty good world alignment.
And that's kind of where it's at.
If I hit the 0.5, you can see my visibility.
And I can see that my calibration points
that were misaligned are now actually aligned in here.
Now, if I were to grab my camera and move things around,
you would still see my points align
as I've now aligned my LED walls to my stage.
Now, if I jump back into my slides really quick,
I just want to point out
that this is the alignment that you are looking for.
And I want to repeat that capturing several images,
20 to 30, is vital
in order to get this calibration to work.
One thing to note is that if this didn't work
and your alignment goes throwing the end display
clear out into space,
the fix for that is to just zero it out and do it again
and get a few more images.
Once that's done, again,
apply your calibration points to the camera parent,
and that should offset your tracking origin
that was previously created to your NDC camera.
Again, we verify by setting transparency at 0.05
and the Arruco markers will align
as you see on our image.
That's it for this course.
I hope you have a good time
getting your nodal offset set up and that's it.